this morning Ukraine's president made a
surprise visit to a key City just freed
from Russian troops velodimir zielinski
arrived in her son this morning and
spoke to soldiers and civilians calling
The Liberation the beginning of the end
of the war Chris livesay spoke to
zielinski where he found a City full of
joy in the middle of War
so this is the road to Harrison we've
been given a military escort and we have
to drive very very carefully because the
road is just littered with vehicle after
vehicle that's been blown to Pieces not
to mention craters left over from
explosives and other debris from what
has been nearly nine months of an effort
to reclaim this area and the City
but the children of hair salon can't
wait any longer to come outside like
kiril and his friends
we are going to play hide and seek in
those trenches once we're allowed to he
says
president zielinski is wasting no time
either president zielinski is this the
beginning of the end of the war we're
ready for peace but our peace for our
country is all our country all our
territory that's why we we are fighting
against Russian aggression
for the people of Carson Victory and
freedom have never tasted so sweet once
they could be killed for singing the
Ukrainian national anthem now they can
shout it Russians promise that they're
here forever they are lying they are not
here anymore and they are not forever
but the Jubilation belies unspeakable
trauma for survivors like oleksander he
takes us to his mother's house where he
says 40 Russian soldiers lived for
months you can see his mother's clothing
all over the floor as we poke through
the mess he tells me he couldn't stand
it anymore so he asked them to leave
they answered by pointing their rifles
at him and giving him a shovel they made
you dig your own grave
only at the last minute after two nights
of digging he says did they change their
minds and let him live
there goes one of the collaborators he
says pointing to a neighbor he claims
helped the Russians occupy her song
how can you go on living with them
I don't know he says and I don't know
how they can live with themselves
and now the rebuilding can begin
President zielinski also told me how
grateful he was to President Joe Biden
and Congress for the American weapons
that have been critical in retaking this
city
for CBS mornings Chris slips say her son
Ukraine
Dennis Chris is tagging out you can
still hear the gunfire and the shelling
there I have to say he's okay very still
a very dangerous situation